how to sell the entrepreneurs so I got a
great question for one of my youtube
video viewers love you guys Josh who's
trying to start a new business that
caters to entrepreneurs we wrote in with
this question Evan a recently stumbled
upon your YouTube channel I must say I
enjoy it I love how you talk about hard
work and passion fellow entrepreneurs
I'm developing my business model as you
know seventeen ninety percent of
businesses fail according to who you get
a stat from most startups don't have the
money to for a consultant I was thinking
of starting over startup assessment
company my company charges a small fee
to review your plan and idea I think it
makes sense to get a professional
opinion and whether an idea is viable or
not they could potentially save our
startup a lot of time and money and then
my company would basically provide a yes
or no statement why Mike up with an
offer full consultant services if the
startup wants to chase the dream what do
you think Josh so Josh I love the
passion of one that help entrepreneurs
is something I can relate to it so
challenging because entrepreneurs don't
have money right startup entrepreneurs
for the most part don't have money and
I've seen so many people with great
intentions start a whole vast amount of
different kinds of businesses with
different models and they almost never
work mainly because the people they're
servicing entrepreneurs just don't have
the cash and it's hard to get paid what
you're worth it's hard for you even just
to survive if you're selling to market
who doesn't have any money so there are
a few ways around it and hopefully one
of these strategies will work with you
the first one is go deep and go deep
means go find one particular niche that
you can focus on that does have money
most startups don't but some do and so I
would look at if you really want to get
this consultant service business off the
ground I would look at retired people
who are starting new businesses I would
look at people who are transitioning
from one successful career to another
you might look at a professional who's
going from being a doctor or a lawyer or
dentist or an accountant and the sick of
their job and now I was wanting to start
their business somebody who's made money
already and now is launching a new
business but the new startup you know
young people
entrepreneurs is really hard it's not
that it's not possible it's just it's
really hard cuz they don't have the cash
so how do you get paid what you're worth
especially consulting services when your
customer doesn't have the cash again
there are a few people there are a few
markets find them go deep with them
second one is go wide and go wide means
instead of helping people in a really
one-on-one way really specific really
deep you're helping lots of people in a
little way and you're getting a mass
audience so the way to sell it is and
this is what I did for a long time at my
side and still do you have a popular
website you can tell advertising against
it you have worksheets or guides that
you sell at a low price that
entrepreneurs can afford that's what I
do with my zucca guides they start off
at seven bucks each that's an affordable
price but I'm not in detail helping
entrepreneurs one-on-one you're gaining
my knowledge through a guy that you work
through you could sell to big brands
like I work with Dell and american
express and Google and Microsoft we're
trying to reach entrepreneurs so those
guys have the big cash where the
entrepreneurs don't now this may not be
the model you want to work with right
even look at this video instead of me
responding to your email I'm making a
video so that you could benefit from it
but also other people can benefit from
it so the net that I cast is very wide
and I help people in a small way by them
watching my videos hopefully in a big
way but it's not me coming in to your
business and helping you one-on-one
because for that I'd have to make a lot
more money and entrepreneurs typically
don't have that cash okay the third way
is become an angel and this is where a
real opportunity may exist for you and
something that I'm I'm getting into the
companies that you love that you look at
the real opportunity to make money with
a start-up entrepreneur isn't to charge
them a consulting fee because they
already are strapped for cash and and
you're taking money away from them to be
able to grow their business right
entrepreneurs need cash at the start a
lot of them to get the
things going right if you have a limited
amount of money then you want to invest
in the things that are going to help you
grow right and and yes consulting
services do help you grow but again the
real money to be made off a startup
company is become an investor so trade
your services for piece of the company
if you really believe in the team if you
really believe in the product or service
then help them grow and this you have to
be careful with because you're not
getting paid anything at the start right
you're taking their equity and you got
to work really hard and they'll take
some time before this company takes off
so it has to really be the right
opportunities and I turn away most of
the deals that come to me and I look at
a few and have gone with a few companies
that have worked but that's the real way
if you want to make a lot of money and
have a real impact on a one-on-one scale
is to become an angel investor with the
business so three strategies for you go
deep target a niche somebody who
actually has one who can pay you to go
wide help tons of entrepreneurs build an
audience and then sell advertising or
sell guides and worksheets or sell
partnerships with big brands and then
three become an angel investor those are
the three ways the three models I've
seen work to help entrepreneurs where
most of the other models that I've seen
just fall apart and I want you to be
successful anything that helps
entrepreneurs I want to help you I want
to see that thing take off because I
don't think there's enough good quality
information resources content motivation
to help entrepreneurs take their idea
and take their dream and turn it into
reality so keep going congratulations if
I can be of further help let me know
believe Lucy watching the video give it
a thumbs up below it always makes me to
do more videos for you let me know what
you think in the comments underneath
leave your comments let me know if you
would pay our consultant to help you
launch your company leave that in the
feedback and you want some more videos
like this click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon
you